one of our favorite guests Pro Football
Hall of Famer Emmy award-winning analyst
for the NFL on Fox and all the ground of
great human Howie long how are you how I
I'm doing well rich how are you how are
the training going you look great
well you know glaze is molding me are
you aware that it's Glazers Jim I'm
going to oh that's not the reaction I
wanted to hear oh no he's still laughing
[Music]
in your head what are you envisioning I
am envisioning like Bo Shannon Sharpe no
I'm envisioning I'm envisioning Howie
there is some big man on campus
literally and figuratively right now
going to go to the combine and run slow
enough for me to beat him oh I think I
think that's real I think you could do
that if you actually that's my goal you
know they they track how far it's come I
mean there's a gym at village not to get
off subject but it is the same subject
okay there's a gym at Villanova called
the Jake never and gym have you ever
been to Villanova it's just a little
Matchbox of a gym and he was our old
trainer who's since passed away in
fabulous guy but I ran for like people
have pro days when you're at a small
school like Villanova you run like 50
times I ran on my front lawn of my dorm
some guy in is you know scouting his
girlfriend were in the car and they
checked me off the box and ran me on the
front lawn in sneakers well it was a
torrential downpour and couldn't run and
there wasn't a 40 yard stretch in the
Jake Nevin gym so I had to start
catty-corner in the hallway and run
across the gym and end in the other
hallway and there wasn't enough runway
to stop so you'd end up hitting the wall
but nowadays these guys train so much
yeah I don't think there's any question
I think the slowest guy was maybe the
tackle from Baltimore
this mama last year from USC mama ran
like five eight and change and I think
if a mama shows up at the 2019 combine
mama is gonna be going down Mama's gonna
say who's your daddy you know I'm saying
you actually I mean I know you trained
you've trained for it in the past but
just just actually just getting ready
not to have something snappin right you
know you know it turned into like you
know those those funny cars you know
where the car explodes no I do not
although as they say in our business
that would be great TV because the car
wreck sells that if you exploding or
popping something I mean people would
say really nice things and they go oh
it's I'm so sorry for rich what it's
worth tragic there's I think you know in
such a great cause and all that but at
the end of the day all they really care
about in that in that production room
yeah by the way no wonder you and Mayock
are tight and best friends because
you're basically channeling exactly what
he'd be saying right now you are you
both guys from the Philly area
all right Howie let's let's let's get to
the here and now right now in the NFL
would you be lost right over that
Oakland thing no no oh yeah let's do it
let's get yeah I did get off it so what
what do you think the Lewis and Clark
route to get you past that no I
appreciate you bringing me back to
Center right here because I did want to
start with you on that front when you
just heard what Gruden had to say and
whether you do believe this is the last
Raiders game in Oakland coming up on
Monday if it is if in fact it is it's
really sad
yeah and it's we I think we've had this
conversation before I started my career
there and being drafted by the Oakland
Raiders and you know once again the
history of the year before I was drafted
they had won the Superbowl it was that
team that was the first wild-card team
to
in 81 80 but the 80 season 81 Super Bowl
some of the greatest players in NFL
history played for that organization in
that Stadium so many historical moments
totally agree at the end of the day
you've been to the stadium
yep you've been in the bowels of the
stadium you you understand what we're
talking about it an NFL team if you're
going to compete cannot compete with
that kind of a stadium and in a perfect
world the county would work some would
have worked something out but there
there's just no money there and and
that's the shame of it because I know
this for a fact
Mark Davis is number one two and three
chores were staying Oakland and
unfortunately that just couldn't be
worked out in any way shape or form and
now the reality is that the team's going
to move to Vegas not sure when I right
now it's scheduled for not next season
but the season after and now there's a
lawsuit which would you know if there's
that kind of a lawsuit you know put
yourself in their shoes why would you
play in a stadium where you're being
sued right so what's your favorite
memory in the black hole Howie if you
could choose one well every banks I
played a game on having gone to
Villanova I was a huge Steeler fan and
could you know every player on that
defense you know loved every one of them
Jill green as a matter of fact the
reason why I took 75 was Jill green and
my rookie year I lived with a guy named
Cedric Hardman and said it was about 34
years old 33 34 years old at the time
old San Francisco 49er defensive end
from the gold rush with Jimmy Webb and
you know guys that I'm throwing out
there the people won't
well no but Cedric was a great great
pass rusher who's also Joe greens
roommate in college at North Texas State
so
that my rookie year were playing the
Steelers at the Coliseum on Monday Night
Football and Jill green comes over to
our little apartment that we have in
Alameda and I'm sitting there dinner
with Jill green and end up playing the
Steelers get a couple of sacks and I
remember jumping up and down and going
crazy and Here I am I'm 21 years old and
you know we just got done playing
Delaware and now I'm playing the
Steelers and I remember art shelf said
to me kid
act like you've been there before I
haven't though no so there were some
great memories it to me it was a that
fan base there is is so rabid it's so
crazy and it truly is a team that
transcends that area though you know
there's great fans in Los Angeles I
think you know I feel for the Chargers
right now because they have a great
great football team and they seem to be
kind of a nomadic team you know and
there's the stadium they're in right now
it's a small stadium and 60 70 percent
of the fans in the stadium or opposing
teams fans and it's amazing in that
regard to Howie is that how he longed
Fox Sports here on the Rich Eisen show
is that it looks like the Chargers have
a better chance of hosting a
championship game now than the Rams and
you were at that Rams Eagles game on on
Sunday night yeah what did we who do we
learn about more in that game you think
if I gave you a choice between the Rams
and the Eagles who did we learn about
more as a viability of a threat in this
year's playoff race well for the Eagles
it's you know they put them stay back
themselves into a corner you know
they've had a slew of injuries and in
key spots
I thought Smallwood gave them a real
burst in the run game and and once that
run game gets settled in and you know
the two tackles you know did a
phenomenal job and when you're talking
about blocking you know a guy a guy like
the Rams have Aaron Donald you're not
talking you're talking about a kind of a
group effort and it's always a group
effort
and he's gonna get doubled probably 7080
percent of the time and you take your
chances with everyone else and you leave
your tackles on an island and you you
know and and Nick for whatever reason
and I I read and have seen people give a
perspective on what's different in the
offense I think you know there's a
there's a when you're planning make game
planning for an opponent you've got a
quarterback like a carson wentz or fill
in the blank whoever the quarterback is
you tend to kind of just say what carson
will bail us out so you're not scheming
things up to help the quarterback
necessarily and i'm not sure if that's
the case but i think they work within
the game plan on making things run
easier for you know the backup and he
has the opportunity to kind of make more
plays around the field and huh and
certainly I'll Shawn Jeffery I think you
know was was a beneficiary of that the
other night all some blown coverages for
the Rams for me you know the blown
coverages on defense or one thing and
then obviously the punt fumble at the
end of the game which was a huge huge
swing moment in the game but on offense
and and it's the same thing you saw in
Minnesota Minnesota decided to run the
football and all of a sudden the
quarterback looks better
the receivers look better the defense
looks better everything looks better if
you can run the football but you have to
be committed to running the football and
Todd Gurley right now is not right
physically and if they can't everything
they do now they miss cup Cooper Cup the
the wide receiver everything they do
centers off of Todd Gurley Todd Gurley
makes everything in in my mind makes
everything go he makes your protection
better he makes your quarterback better
who's an on schedule thrower he's not a
guy who can throw off platform reset and
throw he's a rhythm throw a one two
three go through my reads bang
and there's so much of their offensive
success this year's come on play-action
pass and play-action pass is a byproduct
of what Todd Gurley on the screen game
when they can mix it up and keep you it
is it a jab is it a left hook is it an
overhand right and the overhand right
comes off of the run game and when they
get the run game back on track I you
know and I'm listen I'm a Todd Gurley
fan and I think Sean McVeigh is is a
brilliant young coach and but I really
think Todd Gurley makes that whole thing
go well I mean it's interesting how he
because we saw last night a Saints team
that's trying to find a number two for
Thomas and they're struggling in that
regard and we and you could make a great
case though the camara and Ingram and
even Taysom Hill make up for that and
the fact that there's no one else for
Gurley and now we're wondering if the
number three receiver and cup missing is
is that is the missing ingredient for
the Rams who have two great guys and
cooks and in woods so I ask you this
question when you and the rest of your
Fox compadres are on the air for an NFC
Championship game on the road I'm
assuming you're gonna be in New Orleans
just assume that who's right now I don't
when I was looking at their schedule you
know I think the league did a great job
of at the end of the season these
divisional games as we seen are always
more challenging that's cut that
Carolina game was was that Carolina
defense rose up and kind of gave you
ghost of Christmas past that Carolina's
defense is then they just didn't get
enough help from the offense and it's
obvious that cam is not right physically
yeah the ghost of cam the guys decamp
the ghost of cam present unfortunately
well I'm gonna give two things about cam
what lots of them made of cam postgame
in previous years I think under North we
saw the best cam cam can be on the field
and from what I've seen from cam and
postgame interviews let's get can some
credit yep cam says it starts with me I
let the group down and he's not right
physically yeah he flat-out talked about
how he just doesn't have it in
in his shoulder right now so well and
here's what it is rich he's not a leg
thrower he doesn't throw with his legs
and why I mean but of course he doesn't
throw it as like so to throw his feet
what I mean is he's not leverage there's
not a leverage leg thrower he's not
using his legs Cam's ball comes out all
from the upper body so when something
fails there it's off target and that
hurts them so then before I let you go
Howie if you are in New Orleans give me
the team that's the best you you think
has the best possibility of showing up
there in an NFC Championship game out of
the rest of the the mix well it's
interesting that you know it started in
Dallas and has been a couple other games
and Baltimore played them tough I you
know I think kind of we we understand
what the best formula is for stopping
them or at least slowing them down
holding them to 21 or 23 that Chicago
defense travels really well Minnesota
Minnesota again you know the Minnesota
team we solved this past week yeah you
know III think for whatever reason the
the coordinator and the head coach were
we're looking at the world through a
totally different prism you know III and
that's that can't work when you've got
two backs like that
think about that two backs like that
wide receivers like that a defense that
can get you 10 11 sacks in a game play
to your strengths
it makes your quarterback better it
makes your offensive line which has been
an issue better and it makes your
defense better I think Minnesota
I think Chicago's defense I'm a big
victory often and I know everyone's
looking for the next wunderkind at you
know at head coach from a young
offensive mind leadership is as
important as anything and the guy in
Minnesota is a great example of that and
Vic Fangio certainly deserves somebody
really looking hard at that guy being a
head coach because he's been special he
was special in San Francisco
with those great defenses and he's been
special in Chicago that defense is so
sound so good up front second level
third level really good all right Holly
thanks for coming on as always love the
chat and thanks stuff for driving Mike
tell to foe to the game on Sunday night
oh we had a ball we had a ball we were
we were in traffic it was some parts of
the city that I've never been to because
we were with Jake from from Fox right
he's an executive I knew him when he was
well he was doing some shady things at
USC is an undergrad but we won't talk
about that right now but Mike's he had
really cleaned it up and he's a he's an
executive of Fox no but Mike is not
Mike's not a backseat driver and by the
way dude those are two questions is Mike
not a backseat driver and number two why
do you drive yourself Howie I mean I
always drive myself rich if it goes down
rich want some stranger no one I've
gotta go up on the curb and get my butt
out of there I ain't rich on my feet or
in my truck I'm hard to kill you weren't
in hot you were not in hard to kill but
that's that's a Steven Seagal movie I
mean oh that's the movie this is real
okay okay I know I know just a skosh
about acting let's not get carried away
okay there you go okay thanks for taking
care of Michael Forest Howie yeah he was
great he's he's a good man look at you
blue checkmark from Howie long myself
I've known him since god knows how long
it's over 20 years how yeah it's been a
long time do you let him control the
radio at least does he know nobody
touches the radio take care of yourself
I always say how do you finally take
care partner give up right back at you
how he long Pro Football Hall of Fame
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience